all right here we go we've got uh abu
bakr uh who is the ceo of recursive
capital uh and also sits on the board of
the bitcoin trust i'm super excited
about this uh hello sir how are you
hi guys i'm doing great
amazing i'm so excited to talk to you i
feel like uh you have a unique insight
into a place in the world uh of various
countries across africa that
are at the forefront of bitcoin adoption
not only from what we're actually seeing
in terms of where it's being used and
adopted but also the importance of
bitcoin right here in the united states
uh there's a lot of people who are like
oh yeah bitcoin's cool it's one of a lot
of different you know investment assets
that i have and maybe it's going to go
up in price maybe it won't but there's a
lot of folks my understanding uh across
africa who this is a lifeline this is
you know incredibly important and so
maybe let's just start with like when
you think about uh kind of all of the
work you've done all of the data and
information that you've gathered uh over
the last few years like
what is the importance of bitcoin to
various african
that's nations definitely a great one so
historically
going back to you know the early days of
one bitcoin came into the continent a
lot of it was speculation as you would
expect a lot of people got into bitcoin
hard thinking you know they'll be
millennials overnight that resulted in a
lot of scams coming into the continent
which was really bad for the pr bitcoin
overall but then over the years what we
started seeing especially with regards
to younger generations is
they're not noticing that bitcoin is
more than just the speculative asset or
like this number go up technology and
there's the
there's there's a lot more to it
specifically from the angle of a
superior monetary network and one of the
major things or major benefits that they
do
really early on is first of all via the
integration of the lightning network
which is you know through vietnam for
example is a lot of people are starting
to see that you can actually bitcoin on
a day-to-day both in terms of remittance
as well as local commerce which is
unheard of in terms of using local
currencies number one they use these
currencies having a lot of inflation
basis currencies even in terms of
intra-country trade but a lot of that
isn't already done so so smoothly so to
speak but bitcoin it allows you to have
access to an open monetary network that
is global instant cheap
so it's it's one of those things where
over the years we've seen a lot of more
people move out of the speculative
bubble and into actual use cases like
you know permits like i said commerce
and then leveraging this technology to
actually send money cheaply and the
thing is not only is it banking the
unbanked it was also providing a viable
alternative to those that are apparently
banks because again the problem with
even those that are banked is they're
getting on their banks so to speak which
is having all these unreliable bank
services at the disposal as opposed to
being able to access bitcoin which is a
superior you know system so to speak so
really that those are the trends that
we're seeing and will likely continue to
increase as more wallets start to
introduce you know the lightning network
for example so these are kind of the
trends that we're seeing and at least
the good use cases that are being used
which is thank god outside of
speculation
yeah it's fascinating to kind of think
about uh
many of these countries right in i think
it was 2016 or so uh i think i went to
nigeria and one of the things that just
blew me away was uh the internet
penetration and the mobile phone
penetration everyone had a phone and
they were all in some form or fashion
connected to the internet and i probably
was in uh kind of the computer village
area and legos so you know definitely
maybe like a little bit of an outlier
from just the the local economy but
when i think about that experience
you have to get the internet penetration
you have to get the mobile phone
penetration in order for bitcoin
adoption to actually be present and to
have that solution available and so talk
to me about kind of your understanding
of where are we like is it pretty much
the default now that most young uh
people are aware of the internet use the
internet have mobile devices uh you know
do they have internet access in their
home like where are we in some of these
countries
yeah so it varies because africa is
quite a huge continent and specifically
with regards to infrastructure both
energy-wise and in terms of internet
infrastructure it really varies a lot so
you're going to see a lot more of the so
it's the developed energy infrastructure
around the north north parts of africa
and some parts of the south like south
africa for example in western africa you
know with ghana having 24 hours
electricity and then with nigeria not
not so much really when it comes to
energy and then with internet
penetration really is
it's more it's less fragmented than the
energy distribution across the continent
which is good for adoption specifically
like you mentioned and one of the things
we're seeing specifically with regards
to the demographics using bitcoin is not
only are we seeing younger people also
seeing older generations who are
you know mom and pop stores actually
getting access to bitcoin because now
with bittner for example one of the use
cases we're seeing grow is actually
having these shop owners allow
individuals to pay them in bitcoin using
bitcoin up so they act as sort of this
merchant system where people can
actually interact directly with bitcoin
and we're going to be seeing a lot more
adoption with regards to using you know
pos systems over the lightning network
now specifically with regards to
smartphone penetration like you're
talking about it's really really high
and again pairing that with the youthful
population all that we're seeing is a
lot more young people being actively you
know um available online which is great
for using something like bitcoin which
is digital and you know a digital native
so the thing
the thing i was specifically seeing with
regards to
you know
adoption when it comes to pairing you
know the penetration rate as well as
mobile phone adoption is we have to
start thinking more in terms of trying
to get more decentralized internet
infrastructure here or at least some
sort of resilient different internet
infrastructure so specifically things
like mesh networking and some other ways
in order to have a less of a reliance on
some of the substandard internet
infrastructure that we have on the
continent which we'll likely see more of
going down the road yeah it's
fascinating to kind of think about this
um when you think about uh bitcoin
development uh it's a weird thing where
there's developers uh across the world
who try to build technology for other
groups it could be in my own country it
could be something in another country it
could be for a different language a
different religion whatever it is but
there's a huge advantage if you're able
to build technology for you right and
build technology for uh your local
community or or the people that you grew
up with etc what is the state currently
of bitcoin development uh in some of
these countries and then how do you
think about the importance of making
sure that uh people who not only uh uh
are from african nations but actually
live in african nations are
participating
in the bitcoin development process
yeah so that's that's definitely a great
one and you know over the years we've
seen quite a lot of progress in terms of
actual development overall so i like
people to you know think of development
as more of a holistic chunk in terms of
bitcoin so when we see development we're
not specifically only narrowing it down
to developers per se but also looking at
individuals that are contributing
overall to the ecosystem so we're
talking about language translation for
example which there are great strides
being made across the continent so there
are individuals that are actively
working on translating a lot of the
bitcoin material into their native
languages into you know um
some of the other languages which is
great because you think about it
people can only benefit from bitcoin if
they know about it and if everything is
locked into you know english so to speak
then they're locked out essentially from
having this information already
available to them now when it comes to
developers we're seeing a lot more
people at least recognize that number
one there's some sort of viable job
option when it comes to actually working
on bitcoin and it's not just a bunch of
folks who are working in pro bono you
know so
unfortunately obviously there are a
couple of current products that come
into the continent and just you know air
drop a ton of money and then we bring
out a lot of these developers in terms
of the mind share on to building first
aircraft projects but we're seeing a lot
more individuals flock towards bitcoin
as they realize a lot more of the
resilience that they're looking for in
terms of both freedom and an actual
monetary network to use for you know
global remittances on bitcoin as opposed
to some of these other teams we're
seeing a lot more people build on
bitcoin last one we're seeing a lot more
people get interested to actually learn
about bitcoin both from a developer
perspective and in terms of average
individuals trying to use bitcoin
another good thing that we're seeing is
you know with the introduction of kala
for example which i'm a part of
and the good thing or the great thing
with gala is already we're currently you
know um having you know the 13
participants which will be graduating
into the ecosystem in fact you get
bitcoin jobs so the cool thing with this
project is we're allowing developers not
only to learn about bitcoin but to
actually practically have
you know projects that they built on
bitcoin in order to build out their
portfolio and actually look at ways in
which they can improve bitcoin or at
least improve the usage of bitcoin on
the continent so they're kind of
localizing the context of bitcoin
developments through this program so
we're going to be seeing a lot more
projects like gala come up we're going
to see a lot more people engage in
language translation we're going to see
a lot more um wallets and services
integrate the lighting network
especially and a lot more people trying
to look at bitcoin as more than just a
speculative asset like i said a true
financial freedom tool
yeah when you think about recursive
capital which uh which you're the ceo
and i believe cto of as well um it is
focused on doing what investing in
infrastructure around bitcoin and
bringing it to some of these nations
yeah so we're looking at it at a you
know broader context like i'd like to
say which the thing is
we're trying to be active investors not
just passive investors so one of the
things that we're looking at doing is
providing as much value into the
ecosystem especially when it comes to
portfolio companies are invested in or
just in general so in terms of how we're
trying to look at it from let's say five
to ten years we're looking at actually
having recursive capital not only invest
in portfolio companies but actually have
an arm which is recursive lab they'll be
engaging in you know um
sort of liquidity management liquidity
provision integration of lightning and
bitcoin as well as looking at another
arm which is a cursive research that'll
be dealing with research and development
of the continent and pumping out
newsletters and research reports but
specifically with regards to you know a
question about us investing what we're
looking at is we're looking at
infrastructure as well as some of the
wallets and products and services so
when we see infrastructure we like to
look at it as not only mining we're also
talking about your software for example
we're also looking at um
you know products and services that
allow for second layer solutions
secondary solutions themselves products
that are built on both sides and their
solutions and kind of the general
infrastructure around bitcoin that
enables it to continue to be a resilient
monetary network
yeah it's fascinating uh to kind of
think about just how much work needs to
be done um what's been the response from
the local tech community like in the
united states uh people who are uh
focused on bitcoin they're seen as a
little crazy even in the tech community
which likes to kind of you know hold the
flag of of innovation and and progress
what is it like in uh uh some of these
areas where uh maybe the tech community
are they're into bitcoin or are they not
and like what's their response been
yeah it's been it's been a bumpy ride
initially when we started out you know
back in 2020 which is not really that
long ago but in bitcoin turns last like
a decade ago what we saw this thing was
a lot of people go hey you know this
bitcoin thing is a scam we're not
already feeling this we might as well
focus on fintech has proven how the
ecosystem is there has developed and
we're like you know you guys need to
realize that this is the future of not
only money but financial freedom and
they're like yeah you know well we'll
see and then what's that happening over
the years is you know as more companies
came on you know the bit knobs etc you
know the um even the buy coins early on
a lot of people started realizing that
there's more to it than just like aside
speculation especially with you know
using
um dollar crest averaging through
vietnam for example that opened up the
gates in terms of allowing people to not
only use bitcoin as a savings mechanism
but to have it you know actually growing
their wealth and that was a huge sell
especially for the younger guys or
younger generations so we're starting to
see a lot more people respect the space
or at least acknowledge that it exists
that's one two in terms of the investor
landscape we're looking at a lot more or
we're seeing a lot more investors being
open to bitcoin and actually being open
to investing in companies in the space
so our conversation has
our conversations have become a lot more
friendly when it comes to the investors
and a lot more accepted which is really
great for the for the overall ecosystem
because it means now we have capital
that will likely come in and flood the
gates and actually invest in these
companies to grow the ecosystem as a
whole yeah my last question then my
brother's got a couple questions for you
is uh the bitcoin trust my understanding
is that about 7 000 people from around
the world uh applied uh to be involved
in some form or fashion uh you were
selected as one of those individuals
you're on the board of the bitcoin trust
uh which is uh jack dorsey's uh effort
talk about why were you interested in uh
participating and then what are you guys
doing there uh in that body of work
yeah it's one of those things where
you know it's it's good to be on twitter
is all i have to say because initially i
got the i got the request dm to me by my
older brother he was like hey dude why
don't you try this not like yeah you
know
just this you know little kid in the
ecosystem just being a dove like yeah
but worst case you wouldn't get it i was
like yeah fair enough so i got it and
really the main reason why i wanted to
you know apply or i did apply is because
i see
i see ourselves as having a lot of um
responsibility going forward in terms of
growing the space actively speaking like
you mentioned the space is really really
uh what i say it's really in its infancy
which means there's a lot to do so one
of the things i was thinking about
especially going through the process
which was you know
at least initially it took quite a while
for them to get back to us and to your
point that is i guess not because we
know there are like 70 people who
applied so initially after they got back
i was like wow i'm still in so after
that throughout the process what was
happening was you know i'm getting back
in terms of providing our feedback in
terms of outlining issues and ecosystem
how are we gonna actually tackle these
issues because our lighting is very very
easy
so what started happening was i started
documenting really what i was going
through in terms of the my comfort we
were having all the way up to the
interview process so
that was initially what eventually
marked into an article that i dropped in
bitcoin magazine about during ecosystem
in africa so the way i see it is
in general we're talking about grimly
ecosystem really has to be multifaceted
like i said has to not only be in terms
of trying to get the developer efforts
to a stage where it's not only competing
at the global stage but it's actually
leading in terms of development we also
have to look at things like language
translation which i think is going to be
increasingly important as we're looking
to hit demographics that are
multilingual so one of the things that
we're primarily looking at on b trust is
actually trying to number one maintain a
set of
really rigid principles going forward
and outline how we're trying to grow the
ecosystem in a really clear and concise
way so that we don't trip ourselves up
so that we have a clear path in terms of
achieving the goals that we want so
we're looking at obviously being bitcoin
only that's one this huge important one
we're looking at ensuring that we have
transparency throughout the process
while still respecting you know the
privacy of some of the board members
like ourselves obviously we don't want
individuals coming up or mugging me
or some of the other board members like
ireland the rest that live on the
continent so these are we're really
looking at ways to grow the
ecosystem and that will initially be
focusing specifically on open source
development and specifically
non-developers especially through grand
style funding which is what we're
primarily looking at and obviously the
target demographic or the target
geography usually going on is you know
africa so really that's kind of the like
overall just and like a quick brief of
what we're trying to do yeah it's uh
it's pretty incredible i love this uh
jojo what questions do you guys have my
question would just be on kind of the
progress that's been made in africa
specifically uh like just talk me
through kind of how you think about that
today what i don't know if you want to
give them a grade but just like
generally how uh
how you view the progress and like how
much further there is still to go
yeah it's
like i said
we're still at
like the infant stage is really like in
a global terms really not even at a
local context though
i'll still leave some some room for for
leniency when it comes to the grading so
i'll give it like a b plus
just because you know the development
has been almost exponential in terms of
not only the products we're seeing but
the heightened interest and as well as
the conscientiousness of actual average
folks using bitcoin so
i think there's still a lot to be done
specifically when it comes to
integrating our average fintech rails
which are you know all right to actually
leverage bitcoin which will make it
supercharged and allow us to actually
have a proper monetary network that we
can then build future products and
services and actually lead the continent
away from some of these and some of the
shackles of some of the currencies like
you know the
the francophone countries are going
through for example so looking at it
from the point of view of how do we
not only help with bitcoin development
in general because bitcoin development
is decentralized which is really great
so it means any sort of development that
happens outside of the continent as well
as within the continent compounds the
sort of benefit that we see globally
even at the local level as well which is
really good so what it means is for
example if we have a strike working
really hard in terms of providing
lightning integration all the way
outside of the shores of the continent
as well as having some of these products
and services on the continent
integrating lightning it means all the
access that we have in terms of sending
money abroad and at home are not
supercharged and are now not only
allowed to be really opening you know um
the flood waste to individuals providing
a serious monetary network that allows
them to actually access money and send
it back and forth globally cheaply which
is impossible to do with the current
system then i think we're on we're on
the good side so it means obviously that
we have to focus on trying to
really increase this development in a
way that
obviously is
conscious of you know the local context
that we're operating in as well as
trying to make
make it very easy for individuals to use
because that's the number one thing that
we have to consider if you're trying to
onboard as many people as possible it's
not fair enough that bitcoin is a
superior monetary network it has to be
easy to use for them so we're looking at
ways to actually fund companies that are
looking into this deeply
as i was actually trying to ensure that
we're building our infrastructure that
supports this development too so like i
said mesh networking has always other
resilient internet infrastructure as
well
abubakar you talked about that
onboarding process can you talk about
the education that's available to kind
of get people um involved and just
interested in general knowing what
bitcoin is
yeah so there's been great progress on
that and so initially what started
happening is some of the local
communities started self organizing i
like a really small scale so a bunch of
small startups here and there and then
well no startups meetups a bunch of them
here and there so some happening in
lagos i'm happening where i am
and then what started happening is
individuals recognizing like i said the
benefit of bitcoin is starting to see
more than just
a speculative asset as and then
non-starting theater like a proper
investment mechanism a proper monetary
network by the lightning network gpms
all that kind of great stuff and really
as a liberating force so in terms of
education right now
we're seeing a lot more people not only
translate material which is key and
important but
there's there's a lot more material
available
really in general when it comes to
bitcoin so both in terms of allowing
people to understand how to use it
correctly so you're not address reusing
for example allowing them to understand
some of the tools and services that are
available so let's say i would like to
send you know my friend 2000 era for
example i know i have big is bitcoin and
all they have is a bank account you can
actually use
a service called coin profile which you
just send bitcoin to an address and then
it does a bank transfer on your end so
the cool thing with that is obviously is
not only allows you to communicate back
and forth between the legacy and the
future system that we're thinking about
is we're also looking at a lot more
people starting to
really try and leverage the existing you
know um hubs for example the tech hubs
which is something i'm really closely
involved in doing especially in kaduna
which is trying to use these existing
structures to actually propagate the
bitcoin message because again it's a lot
harder to start up all these ecosystems
from scratch why don't we just plug into
the existing tech ecosystem which is
what we're trying to do so yes it's
getting there there's a lot to do i'm
really excited
as you can tell so yeah we'll lightly
see
you know the continent progresses
when when you think about what's needed
right if you could get the word out to
uh you know whether it's uh other folks
in uh uh africa or folks that are not in
africa what is the two things that you
would say okay if we can solve problem a
problem b this would drastically uh
increase adoption awareness and
ultimately kind of deliver this solution
to uh to the people who need it most
i say primarily we need
we need a lot more quality developers
working in the space because apparently
at the moment you know
outside of the gala program for example
we're not seeing too many developers in
the space and when i say developers i
mean bitcoin only developers because
currently what's happening like i told
you is a lot of tech engineers that we
have on the continent but the issue is
they're flocking over to building us on
these other chains again as a result of
some of the grant programs that those
other chains have and some of the money
they're just
indiscriminately throwing on the
continent so i think definitely having a
lot more developers work in the space is
going to provide a huge net positive
another thing that i think is really
really important is
having the capital to invest in some of
these companies that are trying to solve
a lot of the problem a lot of the
problems obviously here locally so i
think this is definitely
having the developers and then as well
as having some capital and if there's
room for a third i'd say definitely
educational because without that again
if individuals don't know about bitcoin
then we're really building for no on
yeah it um it feels like the developer
uh specifically is a huge uh component
all around the world um and then i guess
one other piece of it is uh you
mentioned um uh translation as a key
piece are there other uh kind of on the
ground specifics that are very obvious
maybe uh to people who live in these
economies but to kind of a western or
more american focused audience they may
not realize just like the blocking and
tackling that's needed to get uh get
this done and get people educated and
aware
yeah so like i mentioned a lot of people
obviously
that have the privilege of being english
speakers kind of overlook this this
common facet of when it comes to
actual education because what they see
is you know i can speak english
the world is english whereas that's not
the case there are a lot of languages
especially on a continent as diverse as
africa a lot of these other countries
are actually in french-speaking
countries and some of the other
languages as well so
i like to give this example really is to
think of it as imagine having you know
all this bitcoin information locked in
hieroglyphics so this is before the time
of the reset system i mean if that was
the case then there wouldn't be any
progress in terms of actually allowing
those proliferation now to individuals
who actually need bitcoin which is
outside of more of the developed nations
that are talking about so really when it
comes to language translation this is a
huge huge component of education again
because you're you're unlocking the
secrets of the universe to speak
which is allowing individuals to
actually know about bitcoin learn how to
use it having all these practices and
and documentation about learning how to
use these tools readily available to
individuals so i think obviously the way
forward with regards to that is funding
some of these projects and individuals
are hard at work in terms of translation
so you know passing some of the
individuals around the continent doing
work on that
another thing obviously is reaching out
to some of these tech ecosystems like i
said they're already existing
who are even you know um cater to
non-english speaking um demographics so
what you'd be doing is keying into those
ecosystems and saying hey you know
that's partner and actually
translational material we have like okay
yeah let's go for it and then like that
you could actually have this sort of
grasp
grassroots movement where you're having
to leverage all these existing
infrastructures to provide this language
translation as well so i think really
that's that's at least one way we could
go about it especially so yeah it's a
huge part definitely
all right before we get uh finished here
i want to just fire off some questions
uh and you just answer as we go ready
yeah
favorite bitcoin memory so far
i see my first pull request back in
2019.
sick
uh most memorable conversation or lesson
learned from jack dorsey
um
i definitely say it's it's one of the
combos that we had early on in the
process
we're talking about you know the general
importance of bitcoin on the continent
it was
at least it was a really good combo from
the perspective of how he outlines some
of the things that were kind of missing
in my thinking and also looking at ways
in which we could actually provide the
change that we need to so it was really
robust conversation i definitely have
some of the most memorable ones amazing
in your eyes bitcoin means fill in the
blank
financial freedom
i love it
uh sleep schedule one of our sponsors is
eight sleep what's your sleep schedule
let's just stay on the night out
well yeah it depends on weekdays i'm a
lot more staying weekend it's just all
over the place
all right like four hours or like six
hours like what what do you say it's
messed up like how bad is it
those just see some days i get two three
hours oh we got a fan listen we need you
for the long haul buddy we're gonna have
to get you sleeping at least six
[Laughter]
all right
all right
look looking forward the milestone
you're most looking forward to
um
getting a lot more developers in the
ecosystem that's for sure
okay
uh the first african nation to move on
to the bitcoin standard is
uh
i like to nigeria but i don't think
that's realistic it'll probably be some
other smaller country a smaller one okay
and then lastly is uh your twitter
account is at i hate 1999.
what's the story with that yeah so i
joined twitter back in like 2010 when i
was about 11 years old so only god knows
why i chose that
oh so you literally just when you first
signed up that's what you chose and you
just kept it
yeah it was too late to change over the
years so i just went you know might as
well just keep it
what year were you born
1999
[Music]
it provides something that's memorable
no one will forget your twitter account
right
all right sounds good
other than twitter where else can we
send people to find out more about
recursive about bitcoin trust or about
yourself
i definitely say they should probably
look at our website if there's a person
related so it's rcrs xyz
all right
listen buddy i appreciate you taking the
time to do this i'm super uh excited i
would love to bring you back uh kind of
over the next couple of months as things
develop um i i feel like uh various
countries in africa are at the absolute
forefront of uh not only the need but
also of adoption right we've seen the
numbers uh that are self-reported but
but still the numbers around nigeria and
a few other countries and so just
understanding what's happening there i
think is going to be a huge piece of uh
of folks both on the continent but also
off uh really seeing here is the true
value of this technology and what it can
do for uh for people so we'll definitely
have you come back and kind of keep us
updated on that along with the other
work that you're doing
yeah
thanks thanks for having me and you know
i just continue the work that we're
doing especially with regards to
fundraising at recursive as well because
we're actively fundraising right now so
there's a lot of comments that i'll be
had hopefully next time i come on i have
some interesting stories to share with
you guys
i love it i i think that uh that'd be a
ton of fun so thanks so much for taking
the time to join us today
yeah thanks for having me all right talk
later